we missed and the Players missed as well
and there's a very clean Victory there
you can actually play The Rook to E3
here wow and that would have been
a game of the tournament
we're giving up a full Rook here just to
distract the queen not let it get to f8
if black takes the screen with check let
us first point out you can't take it
with the knife you're coming on the way
and then white is the one delivering the
Checkmate okay yeah if you take with the
queen I guess we go King H1 I'm assuming
other moves are also winning but I think
H1 is slightly cleaner than H2 and black
just has no way to connect with the
bishop on G7 crash through and we win
and if the queen goes to f8 anyway which
is what uh Irina Crush has done in the
game we now have the move Rook G3
yeah which is not available to hampi in
the game stunning uh and that would have
been a fantastic combination the one
that would go into every single uh book
of best games of the of the year